foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I have a lot of new information
and updates regarding House of the
dragon's second season thanks to a very
reliable source we now have our first
look at Craig and Stark who will be
featured in the new season of House of
the Dragon the young man you see in this
photo will be the face of Winterfell and
Hal Stark as you can see by this new
headline actor Tom Taylor has been cast
as Lord kriegen Stark in House of the
Dragon now I'm sure some of you who
aren't as familiar with Fire and Blood
might be wondering who he actually is
and what we will see him do in the show
well kriegen Stark known as The Wolf of
the North in later in life the old man
of the north was the Lord of Winterfell
and head of foul Stark during the reign
of aegon Targaryen he is the eldest son
of Lord rickon Stark who he already met
in the first season when he swore his
filthy to viserys and runera now
according to Arch maester gildane Cregan
was a Stern and formidable Lord like
many other Starks he was also a good
friend of the Night's Watch now if
you've been watching all of my other
update videos then you already know we
will see the North and the Night's Watch
in the new season
in fact we will most likely see Craig
and Stark out Winterfell and maybe even
at the wall when jacari's valerion
arrives on his dragon as you all know
jacari's valerion is already on his way
to White Harbor the veil and Winterfell
in search for allies for his mother
ranera now none of us are actually sure
what we will see happen while he's there
because there's different accounts on
record according to grahamaster monkin
Lord Cregan and jakari's got along well
as jakari's reminded kriegen of his late
younger brother after spending time
drinking hunting and training it is said
that Cregan and Jacari swore an oath of
Brotherhood now in contrast to monken's
writings septanus stay said that Jacari
spent his time trying to convert Lord
Stark from the old gods to the faith of
the seven now mushroom actually said
that Cregan had a half-sister Sarah snow
who did sleep with jacaries and he also
said that in angry Cregan only relented
after being told that jacaris and Sarah
had secretly wed in the godswood of
Winterfell well archmaester gildane is
skeptical of mushroom's story however
regardless Lord Cregan and jacaris
reached an agreement known by Monken as
The Pact of Ice and Fire that stated the
future first-born daughter of jakaris
would one day marry cregan's son rickon
although I'm not exactly sure which
version of the events we will see one
thing I do know is we're gonna visit the
wall and the Night's Watch while we're
there not only that but it also seems we
might see the army of the Dead this
season thanks to another leak from the
set we know the makeup artists have been
looking at various examples of the
undead now whether we actually see them
in live action or just a flashback scene
is unknown whatever happens will be
something new added to the story because
George R Martin did not have the white
walkers or the army of the Dead around
during these events and Fire and Blood I
can only assume that if we do see them
next season it will most likely happen
during Jason cregan's visit with the
Night's Watch at the wall now I want to
move on to some other amazing new news
regarding House of the dragon's second
season according to rodanian
intelligence this will be the final week
of filming for House of the Dragon after
months and months of filming scenes for
the second season it looks like House of
the Dragon is ready to move on to the
next phase it is amazing news because
that means for now one step closer to
the season airing on HBO and HBO Max I
don't know about all of you but I know
I'm definitely ready for the long night
to be over it's already been over a year
since we saw House of the dragon air its
first episode and I have a good feeling
this second season will be significantly
better than the first and also can't
believe we're finally gonna see the
dance of the dragons in live action this
is something I've dreamed about ever
since I first read what happened during
these historical events in westerosi
lore
yeah
the dance of dragons a true telling by
Grandmaster monkey being a history of
the war of Targaryen succession between
the princess renera and aegon second of
his name that nearly destroyed the realm
Dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a Targaryen Civil War
where my ancestors danced away in my
Birthright
Before the War House Targaryen counted
18 Dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens we would never
be as powerful or as feared again only
last week we also learned that the name
of the first episode for the second
season is a sun for a son this is from
Damon targaryen's letter to rhaenyra in
response to the death of her son
lucari's valerion now I'm sure most of
you can already imagine what this might
mean it is a direct reference from
George R Martin's Fire and Blood when
Damon sent this letter from harrenhal it
set an eye for an eye a son for a son
lucari's will be Avenged the first
episode of the new season will be
setting the stage for a very bloody
Dance of the Dragons now before I end
this video there's one other thing I
have to mention it now looks like the
writers Union have finally reached a
deal with Hollywood Studios to end their
historic strike this is not only great
news for the writers but also us as fans
of television and film although the
strike thankfully did not affect House
of the Dragon it has certainly affected
other shows and films I was looking
forward to the writer's room for Duncan
egg was shut down as well as well as any
other Game of Thrones show that was
still in the early stages of development
unfortunately the actors are still on
strike but this new agreement with the
writers might help them find a
resolution soon hopefully the writers
and actors will get what they need that
way they can get back to creating the
shows and films that we all love now the
writer's agreement still has to be
signed off by the guilds board and
members before the strike officially
ends but they're saying that should
happen later this week so it's nothing
but great news overall I'm very excited
that filming is almost over and I'm
interested in seeing how well this actor
does as the new Stark let me know what
you think about all this information
down below as always I want to thank all
of you for watching another video I hope
all of you have a great day I will see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign